but also they say that if you have less
hair and i've heard this a long time
that hair is like a
um it's like a if your hair stays in
your body then you're more you're
you're smarter if your hair comes out of
your body then you're not smarter
really you must be a genius yeah no
according to history
according to my theory yeah according to
my
flow chart
back off my broccolini get your life
together
it is don't touch me bro i'm not
touching you dude
[Music]
i saw this discussion on uh like twitter
during the
uh nets game last night people were like
god i want to see what james harden's
only fans
bill is per month because like
and then someone was like they need to
have a site
only only fans fans
you don't get ratted out theo's staring
at dudes all the time
theo's bill's just three grand three
grand with their shirts off
oh just pant shopping i was just trying
to get some fashion ideas dude
clothes on we're just here for the
workout tips
it's inspiration man inspiration
that's awesome we ready nikki yeah we're
wrong
oh i can't believe you guys are no joke
bro so i got to the airport i got out of
the airport and i was like oh my god
these people are trapped that's what it
felt like
right it felt like people know you think
you're better than us now no i don't
but it no joke i didn't i didn't expect
to have this feeling but i i was like oh
my god
these people are we're in north korea
they don't live in a free state that's
north
lake yeah like you're going out to do
missionary work that's exactly what it
felt like we're we're in north korea to
help
yeah we're we're in russia but we have a
nice beach that's l.a right
it's russia but with a b that's exactly
what it is dude it just blew my mind i i
didn't think i would think that it was
just like oh my god i don't realize till
you leave right this isn't a free state
yeah because schultz is doing whatever
[ __ ]
yeah i mean schultz was like talking
about [ __ ] like dude [ __ ] you you're
from new york he's like
dog i'm telling it's way better than
here yeah i'm like really he's like
yeah like i want lunch where am i gonna
go
order it he's like that's he's like you
guys are conditioned to that now
yeah that's the crazy part also was how
conditioned people were
because just a little bit at a time it
comes down the pike you know okay two
more
for two more weeks we get this it'll
it'll be like this oh they just updated
another month
it used to be like remember like uh
three months ago he'd be like man
another month
but now nobody even says anything yeah
no it's just like well this is what it
is
it's crazy bro it just blew my mind i
didn't know i didn't know i'd feel like
that i was like oh my god these people
are
trapped trapped it's scary like i want
to leave like put a note in a bottle and
just throw it in the park
i haven't really intense anxiety right
now it is what's happening and no one
cares
i'm so scared yeah they're close but but
it's happened in history before they're
slowly
tight and tightening until then one day
we wake up like oh [ __ ] man yeah
then you then you realize it's happening
everywhere too they're censoring twitter
now
they're signing some people on twitter
they're taking accounts down on youtube
and we're just all like whatever yeah
yeah
and they're like well trump is uh
incites violence you know yeah i get
that but what about these other accounts
like
sorry everyone's cool with it i'd rather
have a little bit of violence dude than
have no
freedom yeah me too you know theo's
living going to kid rock's birthday
party oh
oh wow is it hot tub time machine is it
2003. damn is that guys single dude i
know i'm not gay but i'll [ __ ]
that dude awesome okay hey hold on
leave that there hold
if it's under the waist it's under the
light you look you look like that
you look like you're right and it's this
way
you look like you ride on the bike at
david duke's bike
right on the back of his bed
dude first of all i look hotter than a
lot of [ __ ] step moms who have the
same haircut
i'll give you that you look you look
like you got kicked out of seek freaking
roid for staring at the tigers too
so uh tell me more about that one
hey yeah it's something what's the story
with that one man the [ __ ]
tigers bro hey tell me about the one
with the uh you know the lead
the lean stripes on his butt wait kid
rocks 50 okay drock's 50 down there
you look like you sell fentanyl for the
for the kkk but only to whites
what are you talking about first of all
if i was telling fentanyl everybody's
getting it dude
everybody's getting this yeah dude look
at you
oh my god bro i was lit as hell and
here's the thing
you look like joe exotic's gayest friend
look i look like joe exotic's lawyer
that's going to try to get him pardoned
we're going to get you out brother sit
tight you can make it happen
yeah i'm typing up the request form yeah
you're gonna be okay
yeah everything's good
that's your billboard right there
oh every bus stop you're looking crisp
have you been in an accident
the best is the mexican guy on the back
of every bus he's like accidentally
has the mustache dude
we've always stole nick's joke too i do
want to acknowledge that which one
i brought the energy up this right there
a lot of joke stealing goes on here
and i will say this it usually flows
this way
that the white power is not a joke no no
no he's not mean white power guys
this was started by this means okay
nick what was your joke uh just that
this just that
theo when he tells joe exotic he's gonna
be okay he's gonna be okay we everybody
hopped out
so how do is that is robert whitaker
here in disguise today what the
f is going on dude are you here
where's darren till bro
[Laughter]
bob whitaker he doesn't am i crazy no
yes he does
oh yeah a
you look like a heavyweight robert
whitaker oh my god look at him yeah a
little bit
and i feel like robert whittaker doesn't
take a little offense to that because
he's not asian but whatever
robert could be assuming if he wants to
first of all and jim looks at robert
whitaker after the fight
little puppy oh bro we we got our bet
this week oh yeah
oh yeah how much was it a grand it was
10. i told you three grand you're like i
would
never bet that i wouldn't throw out
three grand
i lost four grand on the uh i thought
donald trump would win and i
that got pretty ugly for me too i was
betting state by state i
can't believe i lost alabama
pennsylvania arizona
put your hair to the ground i didn't
know you could bet state by state i just
thought they didn't
win i don't know there was bets for it
yeah oh yeah you can bet on anything
chin there you go chin yeah thanks you
just gotta grow the the goatee
i wish i could you can't grow it's too
sparse
i can grow it out but it's just too
sparkly yeah it's not facial hair is not
an asian thing no
i got this i don't know we just don't
have that many pores i guess oh you
don't yeah yeah you do chin all right
thank you
yeah don't say that about yourself yeah
theo just uplifted you dog
yeah that's why like cat's face is so
like
flawless because she's less pores yeah
she's also a girl yeah she's a girl yeah
that's a girl she girls but also they
say that if you have less hair and i've
heard this a long time that hair is like
a
um it's like a if your hair stays in
your body then you're more you're you're
smarter if your hair comes out of your
body then you're not smarter really
you must be a genius yeah no
no according to my theory yeah according
to my flow chart
i would be less smarter every year
hairier people aren't smart uh
yeah that's just it's just it's an old
rumor that if you have less
there's like a hair you're a hairy smart
person though alberto like
real hairy we just had long hair
yeah but that's answering what you just
said brendan he had long hair yeah
he didn't have like full body hair like
a big beard he didn't have like nick's
[ __ ] nuts
oh yeah neck down he was smooth he was
oh yeah everybody knows that
dog elon musk is like a dolphin dog
there's no here
dude yeah steve jobs albert einstein's
swim times his swim meet time
oh dude well he's a swimmer oh yeah big
time
big time man with no body hair you gotta
swim yeah you have to
the michael phelps yeah like so are you
jonesing to get back to nashville
i mean it's just straight it does it
feels strange man it just feels strange
like people outside
everybody like and i'm not saying they
don't have mass there
but it's but they're still living they
have yeah they're living
right right that's weird i'm in texas
next week
but again we're so conditioned to it
like when we're in florida i was looking
restaurants people were in restaurants
so i'm like oh
[ __ ] savages yeah that was the weird
part for me i think was just being here
and being like wow
just how like okay it felt this is the
thought that came on my head oh this
isn't a free state that's what i thought
which is crazy
it's going to start opening back up
because new york's opening up chicago is
open up
they're leading the way and then we'll
open up i bet i bet
towards the end of this month february
restaurants come back
outdoor capacity yeah oh yeah i would
definitely think so it was just
it was just like an interesting moment
yeah you don't realize how you don't
realize how bad it is dude every time we
go on the road
it just seemed the world just seems so
different than california don't get to
get out of here cat you've been here
most of the time right no she came with
us
okay oh that's right she came to
tennessee uh yeah you went to
nashville went to florida in florida it
is weird getting out of california and
seeing everybody living their life
yeah losing this i'm so anxious when i
see it and that after
like a day i'm back to normal but it
ain't going well for news so i'm locking
us down that boy about to get recalled
oh that guy's a police approval rating
yeah that guy probably are they putting
bets on that if
him getting recalled i'm sure they're
out there yeah you could easily oh i'm
sure
i'll bet on it there's just no one like
that that mayor from san diego who
blinks a lot is kind of uh
trying to run for it you never seen mr
blinky they just had an article that
came out though that it was like uh
i'm sorry i interrupted you man bring up
mr blinky yeah he's doing an interview
on fox is he okay
there has to be some condition he's a
californian he might be a lizard person
just another time
who is he he's the mayor of san diego i
feel like this is every conversation
brendan's talking about mr blankie and
then i interject that makes sense like
i'll take it from here
yeah why do you have a six-pack of my
card lemonade
mr blinky let's get this fellow winks a
lot huh
dude sir wink a lot here is he okay do
you know if he's okay it has to be a
condition
and if he does have a condition it could
be a white supremacist thing
yeah i think it's a lizard person thing
i've only seen white people blink like
that so
theo has a point do black people blink
you guys blank
the blinking is different though do you
know what's coming though i feel like
mine i don't know they're coming and
then damn it's over
it's like giving it's like giving blood
when you're like or like getting a shot
when you're a kid
yeah it's over is that how it is for you
what's it like when you blink yeah
uh it's nice it's nice it's refreshing
it feels good
yeah here's my thing a lot of people
that blink slow well if i watch him
blink a lot then i'll start blinking a
lot
yeah yeah slowly if i see someone with a
team let's get him blink
okay he does oh that's morris i don't
know why i picked
up on that oh [ __ ] oh that is morse
that's him saying help
that's morse code for give me the [ __ ]
out of it that's a lot of blinking
have you ever seen anyone blink as much
in your life blinks with every word he
speaks
oh i bet his eyeballs are just i better
oh he got them whacked dude them wet ass
pupils
[Laughter]
wet ass peepers dog daddy got them wet
[Applause]
need some greens green up man green
up right now green up green down man
look
in the old days if you wanted to get a
salad you had to eat a salad
yep you know you wanted you wanted to
you know get a celery you had to do a
celery it's 20 21 now so there's
athletic greens one
tasty ass scoop of athletic greens give
75 vitamins minerals
whole foods source ingredients including
a multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend and more
that all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your
weak-ass diet man hey man do it like the
astronauts do you think they're up there
and
uh heaven or wherever the astronauts are
you think they're up there doing uh
with a juicer with a damn you know ninja
machine hell yeah
time for that they up there doing
athletic greens they do the powder they
do the water do it like i do it
upside down oh they'll drink it upside
down and and it'll leave you feeling
right
side up yep take your pants off i put
the water i put the powder i put a
little ice cube in there and i shake
that bad girl up and i name it too i'll
be like oh blenda
belinda get in me blend that up man
get in me janet yes get in there mary
jane
simply visit athletic greens.com cats
join the health experts
athletes comics podcasts around the
world
who are committed to their health every
day simply visit athleticgreens.com give
him a gift give him a gift
i'm gonna give you some d free your
supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs right now
again that's athletic greens.com
cats man you know i i'm really grateful
that we have advertisers brendan are you
i'm grateful and i'm grateful that
they're good and they're tasty
and it's fresh well start acting like it
man what i'm telling you is
that some things that you don't realize
brendan are that a lot of food
is from it comes from land it comes from
the sky it comes from animals
but i'm stressed man i don't have time
to make some five course meal i need
something fresh i need someone say hello
i'm talking about that hello fresh
oh well you look you seem like chef
boyar diarrhea bro okay
you seem like a guy that makes some real
violent meals dude so what i'm telling
you is make it easy on yourself and your
little son and that beautiful little
girl you got over at the house
that's also a son oh my god sorry sorry
i'm talking about your wife man oh word
word yeah
can we do in 30 minutes or less also
don't say jeepers yeah
hellofresh offers 23 recipes each week
featuring a range of flavors cuisines
ingredients so you'll never get bored
look hellofresh has easy eats they have
tons of quickly and easy meal solutions
oven ready
and it's 10 to 20 minutes and it does i
will say this if you have a date if you
have a friend coming over
if you just if the if the amazon guy is
stopping by and you just he looks hungry
invite him in for 15 times make a damn
meal frisk and make sure you don't have
a little hatchet on them
yeah don't get robbed don't get robbed
make them a meal man go to
hellofresh.com10king.hellofresh.com10king
and use code 1-0-k-i-n-g the number 10
king for 10 free meals including free
shipping
that's a big deal brendan the biggest
that's right go to hellofresh.com
1-0-k-i-n-g and use code 10k ing for 10
free meals
including free shipping call me boston
all right let's get into this nick yeah
let's do some hoes in this house
right before robert whittaker [ __ ]
has to sign a a four-fight deal on
whittaker
is he with bellator now whitaker no hell
no is he out of his contract
no certainly you're saying you know he's
the most hyper title happy birthday to
dustin the diamond poirier as well man
you know that
big fight coming up dog it's gonna be a
good one i think it's gonna be better
than people think i do too this could be
a fight fight that's what i think
if he can get through the first round
with connor hiding that freaking crazy
snake
i think he'll he then then it'll be a
good fight the longer it goes better for
your boy yeah
dustin and we'll get in some kind i hope
doesn't i know he watched i hope he
doesn't find it offensive that i bet
against him he knows i love him
i don't think he does at all yeah i i
think he's a math guy he he understands
that you got even money
when connor's like minus 320. you got to
take that better
i think those odds are way off i i think
it should be an even money fight
conor hasn't fought a long last time his
last fight was against cowboy
over a year ago an old cowboy dp the
diamond's been [ __ ]
active he's beat some good guys much
better fighter it's an even fight to me
man really yeah
that's the even money fight it's man
it's hard to watch all of conor's fights
and be like
man i would just be it's like fighting a
piece of paper there you called me
because he you know you're not the
biggest ufc fan he called me he's like
dog conor is good i'm like
yeah yeah there's a reason
yeah five days ago he's like man i've
been watching this fight i'm like yes
special dude man
when he's locked in special [ __ ] dude
but then it's crazy how far away he
fights because like
he theo has been watching every fight
but he hasn't seen connor because he's
fought once in the ufc in four years or
something so yeah he's like
the rust might be yeah that's a good
point he [ __ ] up cerrone too so who
but when i came in the only time i got
to see him fight was against cerrone
since then really except for that
mayweather uh fight which he had not
really
translated that didn't show much but but
still i mean
they fought before i don't know i i
think i gotta throw that out that 2014
fight that'll matter dustin's
so much better talking about a different
fighter that's like watching you stand
up from 2014 and be like man theo's all
right like nah [ __ ] watch this new [ __ ]
right you know like watch if you watch
your old special now that's bad but
compared to what you do now yeah you're
a monster yeah completely different dude
so for dustin poury it's like 2 on 14 dp
to now what
what do you think he did what if you had
to give suggestions to dustin
and half the time in the middle of the
night i want to [ __ ] send him a bunch
of ideas
[Laughter]
but i know he knows it all what do you
think man said
you're a fighter what do you think what
do you think is there a key to doing it
because really diaz has been the only
guy to really be able to do it
yeah i think uh pory that first round be
up be on your toes
don't don't get in a gunfight with him
in the first round and drag it out
if i'm dustin poury i grapple man i
grapple early on because conor's not
known for cardio
so that first round i'd surprise him
trying to take him down and drag him in
the third fourth fifth round
because dustin poirier we know for a
fact third fourth fifth round he's
better
he'd be uh justin gaichey he's eddie
alvarez like he's a [ __ ] as the fight
goes on he gets better yeah connor's
from the g that first second round you
better [ __ ] be ready
because he knocked everybody out in the
first round yeah he's never lost the
first round
never he either knocks them out or beats
them just on the feet oh it's crazy
monster special special dude i couldn't
even make it through a restaurant
watching a [ __ ] woke up about 15
minutes later
that's why i retired me too
all right let's get some kinder stinging
that's hilarious
all right here's a guy who i'm not going
to say anything but has a lot of facial
hair
let's just say i don't want him as my
accountant you feel me
brandon theo coming at you from salt
lake city utah
shout out to culture corner uh what are
we dilated to
up to an eight right now and got a
debate club for you
you uh you cut that umbilical cord are
you letting the dog do that
let me know gang gang
your boy's been through it twice you got
to cut the umbilical cord but it's
it's it gets nasty it gets wet it is
whop up in that bit it is
nuts it's nuts
they give you these scissors that you've
never seen before i got a bid on it they
give you these weird [ __ ] scissors
man
you gotta figure out how to cut them
they're they're filming it
all right i'm gonna bet wow you're gonna
bet yeah it's like it's like a white
purple and then you cut it and all this
like dark blood comes out
what yeah it's disgusting you're
supposed to drink that
are you some people in some countries
placenta yes
yeah robert whittaker
what do you guys do with it dude i know
you guys don't waste anything brother
chin free and barbecue that [ __ ] that's
one thing i won't eat that's the only
thing i don't want to know
we'll see you play boy yeah right a
little wasabi on that [ __ ]
barbecue no not happening that newborn
baby bridge you won't eat it
you don't need that what's the deal like
why do they is it like a tradition
it's tradition yeah okay well the
placenta has a lot of nutrients
are you talking about eating the
placenta yeah it's a tradition and then
you cut it and then they tie it off and
it's weird because then the kids just
chilling there with like this
fresh [ __ ] and after cord hanging off
and then after a few days it falls off a
lot of people will take it now it's your
belly button yeah
a lot of people now will take it to the
benihana and have the guy throw it yeah
with the shrimp throw it in grandma's
mouth who's gonna get it
he puts in his hat hey [ __ ] and this
isn't drawings right here brendan this
is a couple of sentences
and i'll handle it the placenta or
afterbirth is the first organ that forms
even before
any of your baby's organs wow so the
placenta
it forms first after you conceive it
plays an important role in your
pregnancy it connects you and your baby
in the uterus and delivers oxygen
nutrients and hormones to them
it also takes away the waste they make
wow so that things back and forth
that's uh that thing's a k n air filter
son yeah taking in all the junk
wow that's an in-n-out huh yeah in-n-out
burger that's basically a shrimp man
that thing's like a shrimp yeah a little
shrimp
no it's one of those sucker fish on the
glass but that's placenta what about the
cord brother
let's see oh eating the cord i
like calamari i don't think anybody does
that uh a lot of people do it for sure
are you sure
no i don't think so camera and frowned
upon well years ago pamela anderson was
selling a um
facial ointment that was made out of uh
placentas
i don't know i thought it was made out
of uh foreskin
foreskin yeah what yeah you can buy
ointment that comes out of foreskin [ __ ]
really yeah don't say force can [ __ ]
dude don't throw [ __ ] on the back to
sound cool
right you're talking about a child's
nuts
no that's a penis yeah and i think that
was sandra bullock
don't be don't start throwing around
these celebrity stories
you went to kid rock's 50th birthday
party in a white turtleneck
looking
[Laughter]
nick roll some of that footage that we
had hey what what song was kid rock
playing
listen cowboy baby
wasn't it play uh the long one if you
can happy birthday
i only got 15 second ones off your story
okay that's all of them
there's one uh yeah this might be it's
about being fifty
yeah the next one now did you guys plan
to raid the capitol after this
why is everybody white in there
there were people that were white dude
they were working i don't okay
where was this party at it was that
girl scott david duke hold on this is
this is good
[Music]
the record shows we defended kid rock in
here remember that you and i are kid
rock yeah we did when they
tried [ __ ] on him we're like nah dawg
his whole catalog
bangs no it was awesome and i just felt
lucky to go i uh go
i just went man i got invited and you go
you don't not go
to freaking kid rock's 50th park did you
know anybody there yeah did you
recognize anybody
yeah i knew like there was uh some
country musicians that i know that i'm
friends with and there was
um was your boy uh wailing there while
in there
kissing random girls while it wasn't
there no who he was supposed to go but
he had a long weekend he said yeah
which is every weekend he says he's a
little hungover oh he said i had a long
weekend hunt and i'm like you guys are
just standing there you don't even
[ __ ] do anything
who else who else did you see there who
else man
um there was like a lot of like hockey
players there
there was some different musicians there
you live in nashville
huh does he live in nashville now or
does he live he lives in nashville
wait his son was there his drummer is
black
kid rock's kids rocks drummer yeah she's
black uh
she i i don't know if she was there or
not there were people that were not
white there
yeah did you see a black drummer i
didn't see anybody with drumsticks in
their hands but oh
actually but they were serving chicken
that's awesome
different drums for food was it good
food
you know what they had little mini
pizzas to go well let's see this video i
wanna see he's gonna get down this guy
was good he looks like he gets down
over under that guy owns some white
sheets
but jessica
[Laughter]
bro that's what it looks like when
you're in a free state right right
looks like bro it was a blast no cove it
had a good time yeah i'm trying to think
of what else it was like they had a
really cool birthday cake well the best
thing about the birthday was they did a
fundraiser the first two hours of it
they raised half a million dollars for
the bar store fun
oh hell yeah so that was crazy so they
did a big fundraiser
and then yeah and then he played that
song that he wrote and the song was
great it was like a real
self-deprecating
it's like i'm not gonna tell oprah to go
[ __ ] herself anymore just like a lot of
things that he was like letting go over
his 50 years does he still do the cruise
ship
thing the kid rock cruise ship i think
just because of kova they had to stop it
yeah that makes sense
but but it was cool man i it was just
interesting he's a legend
yeah yeah he's a freaking legend i mean
all the stuff that he's been i couldn't
even imagine
were you talking to people are you in
the corner in your white turtleneck no
no i was talking about it
you're white yeah who was the other
pizza you know white though the country
musician jake owen that is that yeah
he's great yeah he's a great guy
girlfriend
i know him so i talked to him for a
while so that was really cool
um who else was there any chicks
there were some chicks there it sounds
like there's a lot of dudes there
i know he named all this sounds like a
real cockfest
with many pizzas and you wore your
sunday best huh
well look she's got a country music
related uh
debate club for us oh this is great oh
and also let's say congratulations to
the family that's having that baby right
there the ladies on birth control are
now
the ladies on how far is eight
centimeters cat do you know what that is
or dilation no i don't know how far you
have to be dilated is it 12
12 is where it starts getting pretty go
time well depends on what you're gonna
have i think huh
true maybe it's smaller for like a small
asian baby
oh yeah but get ready my man you guys
can pop out into one
i bet you guys could pop out in a one i
said i was a big baby she said i
wrecked her body apparently i had a huge
head
chappelle came out feet then head then
feet than head
but he was awesome
yeah that was the only baby that landed
on two feet on the floor
that baby got some sugar in this tank
my dad was not there
you're welcome to go to kid rock's 51st
birthday i'm ready
it looked fun dude you would have had a
blast you wouldn't got in you had a
blast
[Laughter]
[Applause]
don't you have something to do right now
no i'm friends with the fiddler
[Laughter]
that's my father's my boy
hey what's up debate club you're going
to listen to old town road
by little nos x or her
she's got she added a video with it okay
and we'll say in the meantime did we cut
so do you cut the cord brenda your
father now how many times you got
both of them you cut both
and what do you mean it's pretty intense
you should get the big scissors and be
like welcome to this
yeah we're so happy to have a dunkin
donuts it's like a new restaurant
i just brought a large check for some
reason
okay
no more i'm going to bring
my horse to the old town
i'm nowhere damn the hills have eyes huh
at first i was like should we play this
but she put it on tick tock this is this
is public
consumption and the issue is pretty good
what you film so this is
so this girl is saying do you like
little nos x or do you like debate club
which version little nut
little
or lex what's her name
uh or messi lex katie katie shuffler
okay so do you like little nice you go
katie shuffler man
i'm going to stick with a little nose
like first of all katie back yeah but
it's this copyright there's copper
written material trying to pull off
right here katie and
come up with your own [ __ ] katie yeah
just drop it i'm gonna say go newborn
also don't bite me
that's the safest thing she could do she
didn't have any teeth
yeah she's well so bro she definitely
also has a look and this happens
sometimes when you get into like
real regional areas you know when you
get out in the woods
yeah when you get out there from from
society you mean
oh you can't handle all these we can't
handle this did you like the hills house
eyes joke
no nobody liked that joke brendan
there's like a type of where you lose
the chin you don't know where it starts
well here's the thing is there's a
merging between
i believe fish and people
and i don't mean that in a bad way i
mean that you get in a certain area
certain climate certain areas no you
mean she looks like a salamander
no no i don't mean that
i mean you get out into the desert
sometimes like i used to have a buddy
from the desert this big fella
named gerald and he would lay on after
it rained he would lay on the concrete
with his shirt off he looked like a big
grouper
he looked like a big lizard oh i'm
saying he behaved like a snake
oh gotcha because he was in the desert
and he was from northern arizona so i'm
just saying
are you saying she's behaving like a
snake or no i'm saying that
what you're saying is you're behaving
like you know what i'm saying
she's part of evolution and i'm saying
when you get close to the water
when you get close to the land yeah
close to the mountain you get some mud
skippers yeah you get some mudskipper
and that's a mud skipper yeah
okay that's a mud skipper yeah mud
skipper mary's you just had to break it
down scientifically
yeah yeah i got you and it makes sense
man it's like everyone's gonna get to
the finish line
yeah she's halfway through this marathon
of life yeah
now she may come back next time next run
she may come back as a grouper she may
come back as a mahi mahi
or she may come back it might be a tap
i'm serious man or she may come back as
a damn lindsay donovan or something
who's that swimmer she might come back
as uh who's a famous swimmer chin look
it up
summer sanders huh summer sanders
somewhere sanders is lizzie bonds
lindsay vaughn skier no this is uh she's
from denver i should know this
somebody look up big shoulders uh hard
shoulders tails big shoulders
deep in you'll find somebody yeah look
up big shoulders hard tits silver metal
if you'll find somebody there's a whole
row of them
yeah janet evans no car's a real funny
they're both from colorado famous
from colorado oh there you go missy
franklin uh is the most recent
katie ledecky there you go all right
there we go now missy franklin's
the main one though i'm going katie
ledecky or uh
orladeki matsui yeah she doesn't look
like that
but no man so that lady and what's her
name katie shuffler9
she got stuck between a human and
tadpole apparently i'm just saying we're
all
did she just get done with a full rack
of ribs what's all over her mouth
that stuff it did uh it's like we had
chocolate milk you know that ain't
chocolate
that's a thick soy huh it's not like soy
no that's barbecue
uh i
let's watch again huh see if chappelle
can handle it
i'm gonna thank my horse to the old
download
i'm gonna lie through i think
a lot of blinking going on that one yeah
so i guess does she do all kind of
videos i just want to know is this girl
making fun of her that center in
uh someone posted this in the kingdom
stink facebook group okay and it reached
out i don't think that i think they just
came across
listen you don't post that from the
[ __ ] hills of west virginia with
barbecue all of your mouth if you're not
trying to get roasted right
yeah oh you think that oh you think it's
a real session i mean you put it out
into the world
yeah you put that out and it's free and
there's a there's a whole section of
tick tock that is people like that with
like
massive massive following she could be
rich who knows i don't know maybe well a
lot of my
uh tick tock feed is people that have
down syndrome and people that have uh oh
yeah you said that
send me down yeah and uh speaking of
that we have a guest this week on this
past weekend who has
is the the first person with down
syndrome to complete the iron man
chris nikitch looking forward
we said and brittany you know you're not
happy i'm gonna skip this one yeah
yeah yeah now we do have i will say this
we do have a couple of nikitch's coming
in yeah yeah
his dad nick nickname
his dad nick yeah
they also yeah some people call that him
the stuttering racist
he says he's like no this is my name
yeah yo listen man if you got a nice
little lady or nice man
out there nothing like a diamond says i
love you man ain't nothing like a
diamond
well and a lot of diamonds you don't
know where it's from now sometimes you
get a dime and it's got a little bit of
type a or b positive in it
that that's blood diamonds yep but this
ain't that just clean
diamonds man if you want a clean diamond
for somebody and you don't want to
give them a diamond and give them um
what's that disease
hepatitis c yeah wow yeah we're talking
about that bluenow.com the online
jeweler all right for that high
income adult primarily males 25 plus
looking to get engaged or give a fine
jewelry
to your loved one bluenile.com
diamond jewelry cocktail rings man tail
heavy on the cop
gemstone necklaces excuse me i have one
of
those
impossible biscuits from damn uh
starbucks oh i don't know why you're
eating that man
but they can personalize your stuff
authenticity uh
is paramount to uh to affection so if
you want to get something nice for
yourself or somebody else
here's what i'm telling you is the money
you're gonna save by it not being in a
brook and mortar
uh establishment dude valentine's day is
coming up don't
settle man bluenow.com choose from more
than 100
000 ethically sourced gia graded
diamonds
every shape what you're looking for
every size endless selection my word
what else you want man
rings errands pendants for her or him
yeah you want to get your girl a
ziot or something shaped like a damn
lima bean or whatever they got it they
got everything you need
your little twink on a necklace get it
for him yeah and some of you rostabouts
are sitting there right now saying you
know what i'll
i'll think about it and i'll get her
something a couple weeks you're not
gonna do that
don't wait yeah i can do that think
about think about what you did the last
seven years you did you jack [ __ ] and
you got our air purifier at the last
minute yep think about it
now do this pick from a vast selection
of preset diamond gemstone jewelry blue
now
offers endless options ready to ship the
same day son
same day exact same day we got a deal
make your moment sparkle with jewelry
from bluenile.com
and king and the staying listeners get
50 off
500 you spend 500 you get 50 off this
podcast exclusive
only good through valentine's day and
includes engagement
use code k-a-t-s-s code k-a-t-s plus
every order is insured
ships free and arrives in discrete
packaging
that won't give away what's inside shop
stress free
and find your forever piece go to
bluenile.com today
oh snaps doggy your boys fighting this
weekend fighting my boy conor mcgregor
dustin poured ufc 257
going down this saturday and you're
watching it and you and you broke so
guess what now watch it make money
with draftkings the official sports
betting partner the ufc
turn one dollar into 257
that's right new users can bet one
dollar on mcgregor to win by knockout in
the first round
if he does theo is going to cry but
guess what you'll be cashing 257 dollars
bet a little win a lot it's that simple
there's also the playoffs this weekend
nfl playoffs
draftking is safe secure and reliable
making it easy
my mouth is what i'm so crunky no it's
taking that easy for you to
deposit withdraw your money at your
convenience let them know how to do it
and nick had a couple of bets nick you
want to tell them again what they are
real quick nick's picks lose your money
yeah i just realized uh the fights were
yesterday so i gave out
warley alves plus 650. you talking about
that fight night we talking about that
big bad boy
would you have won that uh we'll see
download the top ranked draftking
sportsbook app now use promo code cats
when you sign up turn and 1.250 dollars
if mcgregor wins by first round knockout
that's right place your bet and watch
the fists
fly this weekend that's code kats for
new players to get 257 dollars
if mcgregor wins by first round knockout
for a limited time
only at draftkings sportsbook must be 21
or older new jersey indiana or pa
only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gaming problem
call 1-800 nick davis sorry call 1-800
gambler or in indiana 1-809
with it so what's this feller want nick
i've got another debate club what up
king in the same
fam zach from lawrence kansas i want to
say i'm a huge fan of you guys i'm
blasting you on my headphones right now
while doing that custodial life hey man
bro it's not the most glamorous job in
the world but it allows me to [ __ ]
hookers and buy coke
so i'm not complaining too much okay
young man but that's where my question
slash debate club lies should i
lie to people when i first meet them and
tell them what i do
no way obviously not like a significant
other or anything like that but just if
i'm meeting people like friends
should i tell a little fib about my job
or should i just be honest about this
custodial life
thanks for the input guys and gang gang
buzz buzz
i got a question for you where the
hooker's like in lawrence kansas
cheap i think yeah yeah now you know
that man's a janitor
janitorial work in my first job i was a
janitor and it's frowned upon
people treat you like [ __ ] dude they
really think oh yeah they treat me like
[ __ ] at albertsons
in greenwood village [ __ ] y'all man damn
yeah
listen i used to clean up the [ __ ]
every morning after my
boss would blow it up it's a rough job
is that this
now did i get fired yeah i did because
i'd grab
magazines and i'd go in and pretend i
was cleaning i'd read magazines
and eat all the you know the the five
cent candy yeah
i grabbed a handful of that and not paid
for it and they're like you the [ __ ]
and all these crumpled up magazines and
it was me and i got fired
damn you sound like a bad employee yeah
yeah it's not see i don't i don't think
this guy should be ashamed of his job
that's some good
no grindstone work man that's that's
that's new [ __ ] it's a working man right
there yeah first of all
i like the name custodian i like janitor
you know
old school you a janitor doug let's put
that up can we put that up cpu
okay custodian here's the other thing
young man those
[ __ ] that you're messing with in
lawrence kansas don't give a [ __ ]
they just see money son yeah and i think
look man
first of all i'm also gonna go out on a
limb ma'am and
no homo's bro but um i think this is
this is a handsome guy if this guy
wanted to be like that prisoner that
became a model
this guy could you know tighten this
[ __ ] up get some abs
pose with a [ __ ] bucket and a broom
dog
he could make a whole car bucket in a
mop yeah thank you yeah
or you can custodial like i used to
dude i got fired because i used to use
bucket and
that might be why i got fired too yeah
damn there's no dirt
there's no dirt in here but this place
is soaking wet
and here's what we want to do we want to
tell this guy if he gets his abs into
shape we will hire a photographer
to go over there and do a photo shoot
with him a janitorial shooter yeah
him with him with the the [ __ ] mop
and just wet
just oiled up and then his shirt like
they wear the onesie jumper you know
you take that down wrap around your
waist get oil up that hog
yeah him like bent over like getting gum
off of something yeah
a little too much excitement we're
trying to help him out man wait so he's
got to get bigger
no i think just lean you got to stay
lean i want i mean i want to get
that's where that cocaine comes yeah
yeah you know what i'm talking about
oh yeah and i'm saying if you do that
bro look you do that man you pick up a
following in two or three months you
could be out here in los angeles
banging some executive of a television
show for little to no money
easily probably have your own [ __ ]
cartoon we'll see dude
sky's the limit as well we got high
hopes for those kids oh yeah some people
get to crossroads and like they'll
squander opportunities like this is real
man get a six-pack
yeah we'll take your pictures yeah dude
that's it yeah and by take your pictures
i mean we'll send nick
kansas nick's gonna be with oil to take
the pictures
it's gonna be the lighting maybe drastic
graphics wants to go to kansas
yeah yeah well i think uh we could
hannah barron could go take him she has
land out there she's always talking
about
but no we'll get a real photographer and
we'll send him out so that's a dude
that's on and
now if you don't look good in the
pictures and that's your life then you
then that's you
and i would say just say custodian
just keep cleaning up them [ __ ]
what's this young man want uh let's move
on to a couple uh
more culture corner submissions okay
just me this guy's my nose
what's going on king instinct podcast
i'm izzy and i saw that you guys were
looking for
culture corner submissions in the l.a
area well i'm 20 years old
and i go to cal state long beach smoking
too much and i know that i know i look
like a mix between old italian and a
young extra from super bad but i'm
actually mexican
i was on a mexican game show and i speak
full in spanish
and dude getting into the country
illegally is not a mexican game
i'm just joking man welcome spanish and
i have a [ __ ] ton of mexican border
stories of my dad from years ago from
before when he wasn't a law-abiding
citizen
like he is today obviously amen
yeah i'm 20 years old i know i'm young
but
i have an old soul and i could represent
the next generations i could speak for
the youth and at the same time i have an
old so i could fit right in there's a
little nightstalker vibe to him right
richard ramirez yeah so funny you said
that you were thinking the same thing
buzz i think it's the jaw
wow this guy easily could be uh an extra
will you look up serial killer in
spanish nick
no he looks like look he looks like this
like he looks like the night stalker
yeah not there with the glasses on but
when he's leaning back
oh richard rivera now people fancy him
oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh wow yeah
good one nice day for a wide wedding
that's wild that you guys both thought
that and what is your and i thought it
even before i just didn't want to say it
because it was like oh i just
figured it wasn't worth saying i see
nah man look i think this guy there's
something interesting interesting about
him cat what
vibe do you get from this fella um well
now i can't unsee the night stalker
i thought he was just a stoner at first
but now i feel like i'm getting
murderous vibes
yep that's i mean if you guys want to
mix it up kind of murder
he killed a lot of and i don't want to
say it but he killed a lot of asians
yeah
he did yeah he did richard ramirez did
oh yeah
yeah easy friends called him dickie too
how crazy is that they don't tell you
that it kind of
loose it kind of makes it nice because
isn't there like a whole thing where
he went to war or like his brother went
to the vietnam war
and so they came back and started
killing asian women i don't know i'm
only on the first episode
yeah i'm also on the first episode where
they go balls deep in the detective
yeah it's kill time yeah just past the
first episode go
straight to this number two if i could
redo it you know it'd be amazing if we
got that detective in here
it's a good idea i'll work on it i'll
work on it uh let's move on let's see a
couple more
wait what was that guy's question his
wife is pregnant
he wants to be in the culture audition
well
okay uh i you know what i this guy would
get my vote i would like to see another
tape though maybe without the glasses
yeah me too i'd like to say i'd like to
send him one of the second round what do
you think guys
second round's fine yeah i'd like to see
more i would say out of the submission
we've had he's not really up to par
those two big fat twins that one hot
chick
with the tits the girl from miami miami
you've got some good submissions yeah i
agree
we've also had some really bad ones uh
two weeks we're going to have
one of these people in the culture
corner yeah we're not going to tell you
who yet but we're going to start to uh
we're just going to see what they're
like
you know and try them out well if we're
only having one that means the twins are
out huh
i mean one submission we're gonna have
one embryo one embryo
hi king missing this is luke coming at
you from canada
well actually uh i'm working here right
now so that makes it even more perfect
for
my audition for the culture corner so
i'm no different than anyone else i'm
gonna try to use the pity card
for getting onto the show i was in the
flds cult for
20 years just got out last year and i
have lots of
experiences and stories from that
thought i could really put the
cult in culture corner uh
of warren jeff if none of you are
familiar with that
my aunt is married to him shannon
johnson so
i really felt like i could add something
because i'm a straight white male and
we all know there's lack of that
everywhere yeah tell me about it buddy
and i'm a thick boy but i can still do
that backflip like
chapelle oh you can't oh
let's see what you got is where he
shatters his spine i hope he does not
please do good
oh he landed he landed
yeah well i feel like we see the end on
the land yeah i feel like he cut it off
otherwise
i think he ate [ __ ] face first you know
what the way he's angled and the way
that he's
that's what i'm saying yeah he probably
fell forward because why would you edit
it yeah it's to stop there
you'd walk up and like so gang gang buzz
buzz you turn off you would have landed
and you've been like give me an
[ __ ] t you know meanwhile this guy is
in a neck
brace a full body suit just
you know what i like this guy too
there's something about that uh the guy
lived in a
cult bro how much more i dig that
i dig that and this is his this is where
he was dude and this is the cult
that's the jeff warren's guy he he said
these are women that would adopt you
probably
it is his aunt is married to him did you
say that these women would adopt you i
think
it's it's polyamorous so it's like he's
married to like i bet he has some great
stories now do want them on here full
time nope but one episode and then colt
stories
[ __ ] yeah damn he might be a good this
past weekend guess too
i can see that yeah cold [ __ ] okay great
we'll have them on there guys appreciate
it
i love you guys hey you gonna eat all
that huh
he was thinking about it i was thinking
about it okay i was just curious oh
another
richard ramirez uh this is our navajo
friend he wanted to tell us a little bit
more about him uh
that theo was balls deep in yeah yeah
there was some some debate between you
two first of all colorado is where you
guys took a lot of their land louisiana
bro
we weren't doing none of that i don't
know about that
i know you don't know about it man
that's called information
guy goes to one kid rock birthday party
now he's better than us
that's my life in a slow hill what's up
king and the sting
it's your favorite navajo here
rocksteady eric
you guys want to know a little bit more
about me well i live
here in albuquerque new mexico with the
love of my life taylor [ __ ] asana yo
i love you like the moon the stars i
work for a company called blue bison
incorporated
we do asbestos removal i turned 33 on
the night my face got featured in the
podcast and y'all roasted me
and it truly was a blessing and it was
the cherry on top of my navajo
cake and no not that one chapelle cat
shout out to y'all i'd love to sit with
you guys in the culture corner
nick thank you for getting me in the
podcast and chin you keep singing man
with that sweet voice that makes my
spine tingle
and brenda why don't you want me in the
culture corner
i promise i will not scalp you
and theo dad
come home me and mom miss you
[Laughter]
that was funny that was good that was
good i like him
now is is the way navajo indians do it
is uh 33 is that in dog years is that
like
there's nobody the man is 33 years old
in what [ __ ] world is he younger than
anybody
in here bro his entire imagination 33
it's dog years doug you have to live
outdoors bro don't you know what they
did to the native americans brendan
yeah many movies you have to live
outdoors his whole life bro that's why
they have
33 years ago he's 33. he's not 33.
that man is not 33. man that man is 33
dude
every bit of 47 years old that guy
he can live for up to 200 years old well
he got no gray in his hair as long as
they're not in a big bowl they can live
for up to 200 years old chin what do you
know
yeah i feel like he has a young soul but
he's an old body
i think he thinks he's 33 years old but
he's actually probably in his 40s like
that benjamin button
yeah yeah something like that yeah
brenda's not buying it we'll have to get
him in here and find out maybe
wow first of all shout out to
albuquerque man albuquerque never gets
any respect
for anything unless it's for some ufc
fighters i'm going to say
greg jackson's camp and green chile and
mark maron
yeah that's what they're known for mark
maron greg jackson's fight camp in green
chile
mark martin's from oh yeah born and
raised unbelievable
uh those are our culture corners
auditions uh keep sending them in
they're
they're fun the good ones are fun to
watch so keep sending them in
uh but move on to kane or singing okay
cool so um
yeah but i'm intrigued by those guys man
i'm gonna cheer by ricky ramirez that
killer
yeah um the indian
brendan native american it's called a
cleveland fan
right a washington football fan yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're intrigued by
washington football team
mm-hmm and and the two uh 600-pound life
twins
i don't know i still don't know if i
could cut that cord man i'd let the
doctor do it i don't want to would you
want him to be in the room
i feel like some people don't want to be
in the room at all listen i'm telling
you it's pretty traumatizing it's in his
hands
but i heard there's a thing where if you
don't see the baby come out of your wife
then there's always this disconnected
thing inside of the man where you don't
you you'll no that's not true you won't
always know if it's your kid when you
look at it i i do think it's a real
thing brendan
like a psychological thing no that's not
true you also
they they put up a a thing and you can
have say
take it down and put up i had them leave
it up a cover-up
it's so intense wait you cover up to not
watch her or watch it yeah because i'm
like
to have a c-section on our second baby
boston so you know they're cutting into
their insides
so where are you above her you're just
fighting you're talking to her so you
don't see any of that
you can't see it but you know you know
when your parents will tell you not not
to look at a scary movie or close your
eyes
there's like a little sliver so you can
still see it oh dude you looked
like you took you had to take a piece
can you not pay extra and get the full
curtain
is that that only fans account yeah
damn that's like the only fetal account
yeah that's intense
but tiger wasn't a c-section he was too
oh he was too yeah
anything you see in nick nothing good
really there might not be anything out
there i could have made it up but i
thought i read something but i could
have been dreaming
yeah i could see that happening yeah how
would you know you saw them both right
you were there no i was not i was up
above and then they take the baby out
and then they bring them to me and i cut
the cord
so you're right but listen to theo the
guy with no kids
they got no kids and uh and but a strong
internet connection
great wi-fi yeah yeah he's he wants him
so he's been researching yeah
that's true oh you want them are you
playing i wouldn't mind having a couple
of children man
you might have one out there what about
that navajo girl in idaho i don't know i
don't
want to message her and see what's going
on do you want to adopt one like
chappelle or do you want to like
it'd be fun to have a little chapel i
would like to have a ship if it were
chappelle
i don't want to get like a russian kid
that's going to misbehave well let's get
the paperwork or a little baby kid
yeah adopt chappelle why don't we do it
right now [ __ ] it yeah that'd be fun
i don't think i start paying bills
because yeah i don't have any
where i'm going to have it i'm 34 on
saturday yeah you and me ain't getting a
kid dog i mean i've ever seen no no no
no i don't want to guys
oh two gay dads that's not we ain't
doing that i see where he's going
straight dads my
great kids my straight dads no two gay
dads we could we could have a kid
together and
be straight yeah we would kick ass dude
that'd be awesome after you had a kid
oh dude just monday wednesday cat
thursday
nick takes them on the weekend it's a
cat cat
i think that really is a thing i don't
think so that's called a cult
no that's really yeah raised by a
village where people
who aren't together adopt kids they
won't give them to you
really it's so tough not a thing i could
have sworn
rich people do it all the time do they
have a kid and then they don't see it
for a long time it's just like someone
takes care of it in the other room it's
almost like a tamagotchi at that point
yeah they got that we should get a
tamagotchi
we could start with just a puppy in here
like a cat's puppy and see how that goes
we already had next dog that was in here
yeah yeah that thing was a large rat
[Laughter]
what's his name guapo
did he pass away no he's still chilling
uh when i don't have to bring him i
don't
uh don't want to overstay his welcome
but that's a fair thing
uh kindergarten well this is luke out of
columbus ohio
got a little king understanding for you
i got a new place
two bedroom not to brag uh but i didn't
know what to do with the second bedroom
decided to put a little home theater in
here threw a projector on the wall
a nice little casting couch so now i got
about 96.
you know what you guys think you're stan
gang big tugs and he said he has 96
inches of those dark arts now
tight move young man yo brown brandon
wow look at that starbucks is he the
starbucks employee no that's the
no that's the stuff out of germany who
is this guy
who is that guy on the wall that's
definitely
wow all that stuff on yeah yeah and he
rejected us he wouldn't reply yeah he
hasn't replied
i've damned him from like six accounts
like small ones big ones he's not having
it
yeah does he does it show scene though i
know people on his
yeah yeah and people on his account have
tag king and
like they found him and they tagged us a
bunch so he's got to be aware but wow
well does he have a big following
hopefully he gets on love island or
something he's like jamal charles dude
who's that gay guy that gets in a fight
with
ethan klein all the time pull him up
jamal charles
jamal charles was the running back for
the chiefs james charles i think
james charles the makeup guy
yeah who you talking about oh yeah oh he
gets in fights
uh like verbal verbal fights on youtube
it's like youtube fights online yeah
twitter yeah
like who's makeup's better some yeah
some red vine he fights that dude
dang vernon so what's that guy saying
home theaters or being a cleveland
browns fan
yeah what's it king or sing it what he
said home theaters oh [ __ ]
yeah do they especially right now during
pandemic you can't go to the movie
theater
there's nothing better your boy has a
theater oh yeah yeah who does you do
yeah
i don't have one that's by choice dude
you could have a theater
no i can't yeah you can just put your
roots down man
and i don't know if nashville should be
your roots really honest no where do you
want me to go brendan
here once this opens up you're gonna be
jones gonna come back here you think so
right now it sucks i'll give you that
but it might suck for another six months
yeah yeah it's a long time people will
be deceased by man people we done
yeah not us though you know not us but
what's gonna happen i mean chen's
already in disguise
[Laughter]
people are trying to get out somebody
asked me to take them back with them
yesterday somebody ran up to me at the
market
no they're gonna take me take me yeah
please that person was me
are you taking refugees with you from
california yeah oh that's what you do
now
yeah okay well they what are they called
coyotes coyotes yeah coyotes
and get the other mexicans across the
border pay a lot of money
dangerous job coyotes it'd be nice to
have a famous coyote come in
i don't think they can unless you do
like
uh gang land style where you have like a
yeah indiana covering them
distort their voice oh yeah those are
gangland style
and people like oh this is wrong um i
look i think uh those things i think
home theaters yeah i think if you can
have it i guess i think if your kids
move out you can probably turn the
garage into one
um big boy moves he bit the ufc on that
big screen
that's nice if you're in town let's say
come over on saturday dog for the
mcgregor fight
you're flying back to nashville we free
out there
i gotta get back to kipp rock living my
life
[Laughter]
yeah that one was kind of a slam dunk he
just had a cool video
away here's another king at her stinger
my name is
[Music]
his fiancee was there dude it was cool
his son was there that's cool
you doing limp biscuits bar mitzvah next
or what his son's cool as hell man baby
bobby pull him up
baby bobby who does he rather you know
he had a kid bobby jr huh
does he rap his son he has a beautiful
little granddaughter uh
and of course he is a kid yeah i didn't
know
he did not kid rock i don't know much
about you 50 dog
hey some people ain't got kids at 50.
now is he
now is he trying to audition for the
culture corner or he rocks on robert
james bobby james they call him there's
him and his lady and their little boy
that's his son he's clearly indian yeah
half kid rock half indian horrible child
i'm not sure
oh the kid is and she's like maybe four
or five now super beautiful
so cute it was fun man it was just like
a family party there's me right there
with him
with big bobby little bobby turtleneck
look baby we going deep that hair just
resting right there on the shoulders
i see you though we going in no his son
was oh man his son was maybe so nice and
i didn't realize i was his son at first
i was just talking to him for a little
bit and he was a fan of the show and
just like
being real friendly and then god get off
his totem pole dog
jesus christ
you're right i'm ass kissing man and
then he [ __ ] stole my wallet dude
like any [ __ ] from detroit would
so
immediately i put him right back in that
shitty category
uh we got another kick interesting
brendan theo it's your boy alex the six
foot seven inch
[ __ ] beast in nashville oh my god
i can't get or sting it for you i was at
an appointment earlier today
and i was on the boonies and this lady
said well i'll be
opossum's ass is that one of them dranz
yes yes it is so king of stinger
drones
also p.s brendan i'm down 100 pounds
since i saw you last
august oh let's go oh
and brendan had nothing to do with that
big boy's getting in shape
we don't wanna be stick boys now don't
get too skinny on me and that guy
actually uh literally has giantism
he he like skyped into bobby lee's
podcast oh he's like
he has he's like with bigfoot that eric
andre
uh-huh not eric andre oh no enjoy the
giant giant yeah
land just [ __ ] keep spouting out
[ __ ] growth hormone and they get
really big
damn huge cocktails he said he was six
foot seven yeah
yeah yeah wait what oh yeah and he's got
that speed bump on him he's got that
[ __ ]
yeah oh that thing will slow a car if a
car is rolling up your leg bruh i'll
just have to [ __ ]
reverse and give it a little more gas
yeah that panther tail man
oh yeah that nashville long stick that
boy that was know that yeah
it's science yes science would you guys
not go to science in school
i think i missed that yeah dude chapel
was busy getting adopted every story
she gets adopted she feels like yeah
fifth adoption six adoption
uh baked adoption fried adoption yeah
we got adoption casserole
adoption pie we got all kind of
all kinds of adoption then he stops he's
all
that's about it
[Music]
do we want to try talking to random
people all over the world
there's a new chat roulette type thing
called omegle that's popping off because
people are like putting them on tick
tock and stuff and it's getting really
popular i was doing it this morning
before you guys came
talked to some nice guys in morocco
people cool yeah so far no people did a
bunch of dick pics because we've done we
did chat roulette on firing the kid
and cat got like chin started off and
the guys were like ah get out of here
dude
and then we put cat on and just big
dicks non-stop you don't have to say big
you just say
i'm telling you it's impressive uh it's
not the small ones that are going under
show off though i guess that makes sense
point
you gotta really be confident to do that
before we uh meet some strangers across
the world we'll do another king
understand hey what's up brandon and
theo
and the gang i got a king it or sting it
for you
[Music]
the mcdonald's mcrib you know all that
all that juicy right there you know yeah
that sauce is popping
up i want to see how y'all feel about it
because here in kentucky
we like to beat that meat up oh gang
gang
i'ma let you in on a little secret
homeboy that ain't meat play but
i know right that ain't me when they
gotta form it into the
in the so it looks like ribs from a
[ __ ] animal wouldn't it count as a
patty
it's very it's a pat it's like a weird
patty that's in a [ __ ]
shape of a rib i still eat it well when
i was a kid i see the [ __ ] on that's why
i'm fat now
oh okay yeah my dad would wake me up
it's mcrib months and then we'd go there
damn
every day yeah i get a nice vanilla
shake a mcrib
a large fry finish it off with an apple
pie son
you know what i'm talking about i know
exactly what you're talking about you
get the onions on there the pickles
then you get older and realize that
ain't meat baby
[Music]
asian version of that a mcshort rib
but real like short rib like that's who
knows that's like cow knows we don't
know what the [ __ ] it is
no pun intended a mcrib well it's here
it's gone it's here it's gone
you know it's like it's almost like it's
almost like
the chappelle's dad of sandwiches
[Laughter]
i'm sitting here all interesting i
wonder what i'm saying
i'm just joking it shows up it's great
it leads
breaks your heart it comes back
[Laughter]
out there every time while it was going
taking care of [ __ ] man yeah you never
know what mcrib went through yeah he had
to handle business
yeah they go away and [ __ ] i don't know
you got to hold it down man it's tough
sometimes you know
we don't know what mcgrib is doing when
it's gone we don't know the tough times
that it
you know we don't know what it has to
deal with we just get to have the joy
while it's here you know
yeah enjoy it while it's here you know
yeah do you eat them do you eat them
theo
i don't eat big ribs man i don't know
i feel like it there's always been
something about it that's gone the wrong
way for me
mcdonald's in general i'll do two
cheeseburgers and that's what i do you
know that's what i do now
growing up we didn't even my mama didn't
take us to mcdonald's but uh they had a
man
across a street named mr willie and he
would take us over there and he had a
nice truck and we'd get in the truck and
he had a son i knew his son
and he'd take us over there and get a
happy meal [ __ ]
was mr willie his actual name or like a
nickname you guys
yeah what was that mr willie was his
actual name
i want to make sure
name mr last name
what do we got there nick what's his
intel uh 67 percent of people sting the
mcrae yeah
it's losing its allure yeah well it's
tough to compete with chick-fil-a man
yeah yeah i heard mcdonald's are
starting to put uh tell you what
is in their food now like you know like
with cigarettes and you believe them
no i'm saying like the unhealthy [ __ ]
yeah that's what i heard because them
chicken
mcnuggets are deep-fried snot those
things are disgusting
oh you don't like the chick nut [ __ ]
nuggets why would i get mcdonald's what
uh just like theo i just get the regular
two burgers two
uh cheeseburgers ketchup only you don't
like your big mac
i just want like their meat it's
disgusting
i will say this though nice fries though
this new sweatshirt is dope yeah
you like those fries i really like you
look great in it well thank you yeah
i really like it your hair's getting
long playboy it is yeah i'll probably go
next week
and it's just getting tangles in the
back does it happen you get tangles in
your hair
yeah when it starts growing out you get
tangles really easily it's crazy
braid that [ __ ] up dude that's the point
you braid that up down do you think you
were ahead at the kid rock party this
time wait you come back with a [ __ ]
ponytail a different person right now
i'm in a confederate war
the yankees are coming yeah that's just
dope who's that
oh it's that chat roulette son what's up
player
what's up fellas uh-huh are they scared
how do you skip us [ __ ] you
yeah how are you gonna skip us man in
botswana dog
this thing's their camp their marketings
talk to strangers
what's up man dick
no no no people don't want to [ __ ] with
us i had such good luck earlier hey i
guarantee you put the camera on cats can
get real weird
should i stand in the middle and then
you guys like pop out
what's going on here grab a seat you
want to have a seat
yeah you guys just below the channel
you know who's on this a lot allie
mikowski is she
always on this
i have four people i love how the one
thing your parents tell you to grow up
growing up is do not talk to strangers
the tagline of this thing is omegle talk
too strange
their their marketing is talk to
strangers
yeah oh what the
and there's a child right there hello
yeah what is going on that's a kid
that was a teacher there are a lot of
kids on this there's no age limits dude
i got
four regular adults when no one was here
they were just guys in morocco
teenagers on here really yeah hey
oh wow i'm telling you they're looking
crazy jack it off
i'm not i'm not either but i'm telling
you if we put cat in the middle it's
gonna get wet
cat jump in the middle yeah okay we
could have cat in here by itself and
let's see
what happens let's try it let's just
experiment have cat in here yeah we'll
get out of the way
yeah do you and i just stay off the
camera you'd like to stay here
you come in at the end you're the
[ __ ] bad dad okay should i just be in
the middle or yeah and then you take
your clothes off
okay hey no no no give me your clothes
sit down
hi
hi how are you
good how are you i'm good what's your
name
uh king king i'm kat nice to meet you
king king the sting yeah king the sting
that's what they call me that's what you
they call you why do they call you that
uh you got a stinger on you what's
happening
well i i used to carry a blade yeah
and it's called sting
oh really what'd you do with that blade
well
uh it shows me when uh orcs
or trolls are nearby um how often did
you run by a troll or an orc
well it would glow so like
quite a bit oh would you glow harder for
an orc or a troll
it glows the same does your stinger glow
my stinger will blow okay what's up
young man
[Music]
how are you doing i'm all right brother
what are you up to on this what
what is it tuesday afternoon what are
you what's going on buddy
king stuff oh my god
oh my god hi hella holla
face time
i feel like these are children this is
creepy man
yeah is this a sex trafficking uh
website what the [ __ ] that's the best
enemy
all right king stuff king stuff
they're probably freaked out by the mics
probably yeah there's a whole set behind
you too
people were excited when i was talking
to before they were like oh what's king
and sting it was just a regular guy
morocco he's just hanging out
in morocco
hi how are you
when they see me they flip out well it's
also weird that there's a whole set
behind me
oh damn i know i want somebody to
recognize king in this thing
there's some help it just shows you've
got a large fan base to get a hold of
[Music]
can you hear us
this isn't real this isn't real oh i've
seen these on
hi hey what's up
you got a whole ass setup yeah i'm
calling in from work i'm bored right now
what are you up to
uh i'm going around asking people to
guess my age oh uh
i'd say 15.
no hmm he's affinity he's 19. higher or
lower
is that your final answer uh 19.
final answer finally all right i'll put
it in the chat
cool how old are you
i'm 13. 13. all right see ya
this
and that's how nick lives that's what
the
dark arts brother that's what i was
waiting for and that is nick
in a nutshell i was so excited it worked
so well i was like we're gonna meet some
people there's some weird [ __ ] yeah bro
that was creepy and then we had to see a
man about a horse at the end
uh i don't think we can take any more
man no i can't
definitely can't take that yeah all
right yeah i'm all set
the mcrib is back
i think you and fake bob whitaker over
there we've had a [ __ ] novice
these guys got a great video that i
definitely should be seeing
all right yeah wow wow
a little palette cleanser yeah thank you
looking this thing i'm tiny i'm leo h2o
we got a debate club
for you the battle between two tacos on
one side we got a taco represented by
brendan shaw himself
the guy that keeps campbell's soup in
his cupboard
only the chunky time and on the other
side we've got that theo von taco
that's the guy that goes noodling but he
uses someone else's pathetic arm
on the red corner we got that bbn taco
that big beautiful mexican taco
that big beautiful man taco that thick
thick thick made with that
gobidia for the goat himself topped with
schwab sauce
guac radish and that roasted
jalapeno and roasted onion wow yes
fellas
on the red corner we got that southern
headed you know what i'm saying what do
you think about when you think about the
south
the crawfish boil oh yeah yeah you got
that crawfish over here but put it on
the improvise
you gotta use that crosstalk that
corn green onions yeah
comeback sauce you down 20 points you
[ __ ] get that sauce you come right
back you know what i'm saying
girls man you're a girl you're just
gonna come back when you make that sauce
haven't seen your dad in 20 years
make that
[Music]
big beautiful mexicans
i love these guys yo where are they
located
they look like the brothers off the
movie turbo yeah their company called
it's hilarious i need to [ __ ] go
there it's out here
well if it's a taco trunk i'll have them
on food truck diaries yeah you should
yeah i got cody garbrandt on friday you
do
yeah no way with the neck tattoos yeah
wow
mike tyson was a weird one dude it
seemed weird oh your video of when you
called him sir is so funny bro
yes sir yes sir guess what else is
happening this week
um
you're a year older than the indian yeah
look at me i'm 34. he is not
growing up he's in native american years
no my friend my homie ferris he's native
american and he looks like
he's in his 20s yeah but he's also named
after a carnival ride yeah
ferris native american nobody's buying
this yeah he is
what's his real name ferrous it's short
for ferris the day is long
so this guy's uh tiny's tacos and
they're kind of like taco
yeah and they're they're in l.a
yeah yeah you have one food truck
i like that thick taco got it looked
[ __ ] fresh
yeah i'm doing it next time we do a show
in l.a we have to have them come out yep
once things are open yeah once you guys
are allowed to be free man i'll tell you
what it's like i mean say you guys
i'm just saying you guys i i don't want
to tell you what it's like but it's like
uh
what's it like like it's just crazy man
like you you see people and you can look
at them and everybody's
happy do they yell at you huh do they
yell at you for nothing no you can walk
into a business and say hello and people
are in there
wow and you can get stuff and you can
leave if you want i believe where you
could stay
wow or you could stay yeah yeah living
the dream brother you made it up
you made it out god man it's special i'm
going to tell you what it's like man
is that it dick that's it well thank you
sorry about that one incident but pretty
good show otherwise
i was jacking it man no doubt bro why
how do you look that long to know that
i did i knew immediately i didn't care i
didn't know what it was i was like is
that a mcrib i don't know what that is
i don't know i didn't know that's how
they make the microwave
that was a black dick i just want that
you don't know that brand
dude he could have been in the sun
laying on his back i've seen my shirt of
dicks that's a black one
okay yeah what that was an eggplant uh
i'm in san marcos next week friday
saturday um
where am i san marcos taxes so yeah
i'm in nashville last night
[Laughter]
were you doing a set of zany's missed me
there yeah they said at zany's last
night
and how'd it go what else is going on oh
i think it was great i think it was
great that's what i'm hoping for
yeah i don't have any real dates on the
books man might be trying to find
something for valentine's day down in
tampa but i don't know yet
so that'd be nice glad you're back
brother gang man good to see you
thick boy specialized collab drops this
friday son
specialize your boys would specialize it
looks good thanks man looks really good
man
i got something for you you do i'd like
some
all right man if you also need me i'll
be at nashville mma next week getting my
ass beaten by men and women
your boy michael chandler his big fight
coming up oh yeah dan hooker what do you
think is going to happen
uh tough fight for chandler i bet he
gets it done by decision
wow i'll [ __ ] fight though man i can
see hooker winning
if he goes decision chandler wins if
it's a stoppage it's your boy hooker
i think you guys are underestimating
michael chandler man i'm not i'm saying
he's gonna win
oh yeah that's true my bad man i was
just trying to i was trying to like take
the alternate angle but
would be the same angle so i think uh i
think it's gonna be a great fight i hope
it's a draw i hope that they both win
both them i mean i know michael but dan
seem like a great guy too yeah i like
dan yeah
but i mean hey it's great for that
division i think both of them will have
many opportunities to fight the other
beasts in there as well
you know i'd love to see chandler and
gaichy go at it that's a great fight
god but this is chandler's first big
fight what do you think it's like or in
the ufc what do you think it's like
foreign
is it different animal different animal
do you think he feels like a like a
you think he'll like will it affect the
way that he goes into the fight like i
bet it does
like those ufc nerves i don't care if
give a [ __ ] if you're a bellator champ
or whatever they ain't nothing like
fighting ufc
big big boy moves different animal yeah
damn it's exciting dude this weekend
nick woody on the betting odds what are
you going to tell us
uh nick's picks i'm staying i'm staying
away
from that main event i think
they'd be going some random [ __ ]
guess who else is back
the guy who went away khalil roundtree's
back oh yeah i love khalil i think it's
the last fight though
i can't dude i i thought every fight
i've seen of his he's unbelievable
no he lost his last when he got knocked
down oh by nobo
yeah by johnny walker and it affected
him pretty did it did give him
concussions or something why did it
yeah well he's talking about he he's
only doing one more this is his
retirement fight
he moved to thailand great story though
great story he used to be 300 pounds
did he really i should train with him i
can't even watch his instagram because
it makes me feel like i'm not doing
anything
clear around your grade story yeah man
eat the [ __ ] out of all of us at black
house
i got like magni's on there
actually wednesday morning that the
early prelims start at 6 00 a.m here wow
oh wow
nine am uh main card i love that [ __ ]
wake up and watch them
because i gotta work but yeah i feel you
nick i've really been trying to pick my
spots because i've been getting murdered
i don't
i just don't know what i'm talking about
so don't follow me but in this one
lazaz versus worley alves if you bet
elvis by
submission and lizzezz by knockout it's
plus 650 and plus 150
i literally don't know how you lose
money on that one
dude how about how about my bills alumni
bill's alumni was on team for two days
damn dang dang
papi uh yeah man i i joined the bill's
mafia man saints lost it was
heartbreaking well we're
we're looking at your application
and yeah i'm i'm in man i'm in dude
all right brother back brendan and theo
fighter and weight i gotta go in and go
hard in the paint i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude got a
pack of matches in his pockets at all
times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]